led by his passion for perfectionism
determination and a heroic work ethic
musk has succeeded in markets that were
previously considered impossible to
conquer
my initial Impressions were just that he
was very focused and very passionate on
what he was about to do
he excelled in science and he also
excelled in computer studies the story
of Elon musk's wealth and his Rises is
tied up in part with the American dream
he started working on computers at the
age of 10 working very hard on it and
being very clever in developing programs
Elon was asked about what sets him apart
from other people and he himself said
there were things that were very obvious
to him growing up that other people
didn't understand